From the Hill Country in Texas, broadcasting worldwide, this is OneRadioNetwork.com
Well, a very pleasant good morning to you. It's a little bit, well, whatever it is. It's
December 20 is what it is. You don't care what time it is. You have a clock on the wall
if you want to see that. This is Patrick Timpone. Good morning, and it's great to be here.
It's the third Monday of each month following Richard Massey. We have one of our fave guys,
and a fellow that I have so much respect for is Dr. Ray Peat, PhD in biology long ago,
University of Oregon, where he still lives today in Eugene. Spent a lot of time way down
in Mexico. He did quite a bit of research long ago on progesterone, hormones, and how
progesterone and hormones are related. This was way back in '68 when I started in radio.
The key idea was that energy and structure are independent in every level. He talked
about how progesterone projects the body's structure and energy against the harmful effects
of estrogen, radiation, stress, and lack of oxygen. Certainly a lot of things that we
have today, and we have a lot of fun talking to him. I need some water. Excuse me. Whoops.
Let me grab it here. Let me grab it here. A little water. It's been very dry here.
Cold and dry, which is kind of nice, like 40 degrees at night and 75 in the afternoon.
So it's been really a beautiful time to be here in Central Texas. What I was about to
say, while I was so rudely interrupted by my dry throat, is that if you care to ask
a question of Dr. Peat, we already have a lot of great ones, and we'll try to get to
all of them. Patrick@OneRadioNetwork.com. Patrick@OneRadioNetwork.com. After Dr. Peat,
I'm going to come on and do another little segment. This is the last show we're going
to do between now and January 3. I'm going to take some time off and work on the screenplay
and whip it into shape, continue to rewrite and rewrite. I thought it'd be fun to kind
of connect with you one-to-one before we go off on a little vacay. So right after Dr.
Peat's show, we'll come back on and talk about some of the news and play around a little
bit before we go on our vacation. Dr. Ray Peat is, as I said, in Oregon, and we're going
to say hi to him. Dr. Peat, good morning to you, sir. Thanks for coming on.
Dr. Peat>> Good morning.
Patrick>> Well, here we are. Man, we made another year, Doc. I don't know how we did
it.
Dr. Peat>> Yep.
Patrick>> It's really been something, isn't it, the last couple of years with this whole
virus thing? Pretty interesting, isn't it?
Dr. Peat>> Yeah. I think the population is sort of deciding what they believe and not
going to learn much more. It looks like about half and half, even people who got vaccinated,
are realizing that what the government says is seldom true.
Patrick>> Yeah.
Dr. Peat>> And the other half knew all along that you can't trust the government.
Patrick>> So interesting, isn't it, Dr. Peat, of how is it possible that we could really
trust the science when they just keep making things up?
Dr. Peat>> Yeah. Fauci's principle is, "I am science. Trust me."
Patrick>> That's right.
Dr. Peat>> And that's exactly what science isn't. Science is a matter of questioning
science. It isn't science if it isn't questionable.
Patrick>> And the idea that there... Is there such a thing as a consensus? I mean, how does
it work? How do you scientists really figure out... Do you just come to your own conclusion
of what's true?
Dr. Peat>> Oh, the consensus. I had an interesting exchange with a researcher a few years ago
and doubted something that she had said and asked for a copy of the paper. And I read
the paper through three or four times and couldn't find a trace of what the title said
it was about. And so I mentioned it to her and she, three or four times, said, "You didn't
read it carefully." And finally I said, "That title claim is absolutely not represented
any more in the paper." And she said, "But that's the consensus."
Patrick>> Oh, that's the consensus.
Dr. Peat>> That's what people believe. So she doesn't have to support it in any way.
And how consensus... The Tao Chi thing is a very clear example. He has some power over
government officials that keep him in his office, despite conflicts of interest, going
back to his very beginning in the office. But for some reason, the politicians are powerless
to fire him. And so that power he has is where the consensus comes from. And in the society
in a bigger sense, going back 70 or 80 years, we can see the government directly getting
involved in all of the major scientific questions, biological, physical, sociological, and so
on. The government intervened with its grant power. Science was turning away from individual
researchers with a little self-financed lab. It wasn't acceptable science if it didn't
have financing. And so government and the huge corporations controlled financing to
direct science to go the way they wanted it. And just before the Second World War was when
the giant corporations were essentially taking over government regulation and financing of
science research and directing how the science journals would publish, how the universities
would teach. They wouldn't support grants to the universities if they taught the wrong
things. And so the corporations working with and through the government have created a
consensus of power, the beliefs the corporations wanted to instill that were acceptable to
the government. So the combination of government and big corporations are the consensus. And
if you dissent, you don't get any funding. Do you remember Peter Griesberg and the AIDS
controversy? I heard the story that at the height of his rejection by the establishment,
a high official phoned him and said he wanted to talk to him personally. So he flew across
the country and invited Griesberg to dinner. And after they ate, he pulled out a paper,
an article saying that HIV causes AIDS. And it was written supposedly by Peter Griesberg.
And the guy said, if he signed on to that, and let him publish it under his name, that
he would no longer be an outcast. He would get his grants again and be invited to the
scientific meetings and so on. And naturally, Griesberg refused and stayed an outcast.
Do you think it's to the whole Fauci connection and these drugs that were killing this gay
community with an HIV thing that really never existed? Is that true?
That's my belief and that's Peter Griesberg's. And I've gone through everything Griesberg
has published on the subject and talked to him. One of the crucial things that I had
read about that he said was an unavoidable consideration was that the military recruits
in 1960s, blood samples were taken and frozen from all of the potential draftees. And going
back in the age of HIV and AIDS, those blood samples were tested. And it was found that
over the years of freezing, all of the 18 year old men in the country were given a blood
sample in those years. Every year, the blood tested about, and I don't remember whether
it was 0.4 or 0.5 percent positive for HIV. So the whole population, 30 years before AIDS
was known, showed exactly the same proportion of the population as being HIV positive as
exists at present. It's a resonant component of our makeup of about 0.4 or 0.5 percent
of the people with this inert antigen of the HIV virus.
So we all, that's why Rich, actually my good friend and biological dentist, Dr. Stuart
and Lindley, they have found this HIV thing in root canals.
Yeah, it's going to be in half percent of everyone you test. If you, Duesberg points
out that our liver is full of probably thousands of these remnant viruses. Not even sure that
they were ever functioning as a virus, but they have the structure of a virus. They could
be pollen you inhaled.
Who knows. Like this exosome idea, Dr. Peat?
Yeah. Anyway, they are resonant in our tissues just as part of, they call it the dark DNA.
It only takes a very small percentage of our genome DNA to make, to describe a person.
Something like 97 percent of it is mysterious, so-called dark DNA.
Dark DNA.
In that, there are thousands of these inert virus remnants. So that if you're sick, your
tissues are stirred up, the genome is activated and disturbed and lets out a relatively broad
spectrum of this dark DNA. Duesberg suggests that HIV is just one of these, but it would
account for sick people testing positive more than healthy people. But in the general population,
it's about a half percent test positive.
So with sick, then we can also argue that that's really could be the healing process
as well.
Yeah. The liver is putting out sort of hypotheses about what might help to repair the stress.
So it's an explosion of variability. And if you test for that variability, you see things
that are associated with people being sick, but it doesn't mean that they have anything.
They have anything. So then this is why the famous videos are out there that we've streamed,
Dr. Peat, on our show, on our network from Kerry Mullis, the Nobel Prize winner for the
PCR test. And he very clearly says, if you spin this thing high enough, you can come
up with thousands of things it'll find.
Yeah. And the government instructions right from the start-
It's 45, right?
Yeah. Twice as many as you knew would produce false positives. So what they did was create
an epidemic of tests. The more tests they did, exactly corresponding to the increase
in the number of tests, the increase in the number of so-called cases increased.
Yes.
And so the cases were simply a reflection of how many people you tested.
And so this whole thing was run on false data that nobody's talked about except alternative
places like here. And other people have, but just a handful compared to media.
And suddenly when the virus, when the vaccine came on the market, the government said, "Okay,
now you can run it to normal 30 or 35 cycles and that'll make it look like we're curing
the disease because there'll be fewer positives."
Oh, so they can change the spins.
Yeah.
They probably do that with an email or a telegram, whatever, the connection with the PCR test
company. Well, when they did the whole AIDS thing in the late '70s and around '80,
was it a similar, do you know, Doc, PCR type test where they came up with some kind of
identification of this molecule, HIV?
No, I don't think that came until later.
So what did they use?
The antigen, I think, was the main specific identifier.
The antigen.
Antibody, antigen reactions.
Which is part and parcel of the molecules at the release. The liver just kind of throws
out when things are going on?
Yeah. For many years, the antibody, you would put some of the sample in an animal and elicit
antibodies to it and then concentrate those antibodies and use it to identify the substance.
You can still make a microscopic image of something by applying the right type of antibody
to the microscope slide and the specific antibody will be labeled with either a dye or radioactive
isotope so that you can make a picture of specific types of protein antigens.
So there's many views, of course, on the idea of this isolation and you're on record saying,
well, it doesn't really need to be isolated to maybe to cause or affect people and be
shared, and that's fair enough.
But if there, whatever this original COVID thing is or isn't or out of a lab or natural,
could this entity, if it exists, actually mutate into another thing called Delta or
Omicron? Is that even possible?
Oh, yeah. You can engineer, you can start with a bat virus or any kind of a known transmissible
virus-like agent and then using the DNA engineering techniques that have developed over the last
50 or 60 years, you can change individual amino acids or you can take out a block and
put in a new block that has a known function.
So you can write your own virus program, essentially. That's what Ralph Berrick and his lab at the
University of North Carolina and the Port Dietrich Germ Warfare Lab, what they specialize
in is creating gain-of-function viruses where you make a harmless animal virus able to infect
a human being and then to make it more or less virulent by adding a stretch of DNA that
increases certain activities.
And Dr. Peat, if one did that, how would they distribute that to people?
During World War II, the Germans and Japanese were leaders in germ warfare, but the U.S.
recruited their germ warfare experts instead of hanging them. They came to work for the
U.S. government and at that time, the Fort Dietrich Lab was just one of two or three
major germ warfare experimental labs.
The author of the best-selling medical physiology textbook, Arthur Guyton, was working for the
Germ Warfare Lab right at the end of World War II, and his specialty was to make aerosols
out of germs such as a polio virus to make it survivable and transmissible through the
air. The government was experimenting. They would use a marker bacterium as something
that was easy to find when it infected people. They sprayed San Francisco, for example, with
an aerosol of a bacterium that produced a very visible response in the individual without
especially making them sick. So they were testing it on innocent American populations.
In the process of making aerosols from the polio germs, Arthur Guyton became a polio
doctor and retired to teach medical physiology at the University of Mississippi and write
his famous but very stupid textbook.
But, you know, there are people that are really arguing that the polio thing was really never
about a "virus" and more about DDT and chemical poison.
Yeah, but the government believed in the potential of the virus.
Oh, they believed in it?
Yeah.
Wow, fascinating.
Dr. Ray Peat is with us, Patrick Timpone, OneRadioNetwork.com. We have lots of questions,
Doc. We'd like to get to as many as we can so we don't use up too much of your time because
I know you've got to go Christmas shopping. So we're going to take a quick little break
here, and we'll be right back and get your e-mails. So here we go.
This conversation goes back seven years with Dr. Patrick Flanagan. Listen.
And then I discovered that HUNZO water also contained negative ionized hydrogen, which
is a source of biological electrons. When we're young, we have enzymes in our body called
dehydrogenase, and the purpose of dehydrogenase is to lift off hydrogen ions from the foods
we eat, and their purpose is to create NADH, which is a chemical that acts as a shuttle
in the mitochondria for producing all the energy in our body, adenosine triphosphate.
And when people take this, it causes DNA repair. It heals the body from all kinds of oxygen-free
radicals. It also helps the body recover from damage from radiation.
Well, we certainly want some of this stuff, right? Check out our AquaCure machine. AquaCure
machine on OneRadioNetwork.com. Lifetime warranty. And along with the lifetime warranty, a one-year,
no questions asked, money-back guarantee if you don't like your results. Breathe the gas,
bubble the water. Listen to what Dr. Flanagan has to say about this and others. The AquaCure
machine on OneRadioNetwork.com. Use promo code OneRadio. 10% discount. We love ours.
I think you'll enjoy it. I do it a lot. Drink the water, more breathing the gas. And I got
myself a 25-foot cannula. And it's Brown's gas. And you can go on molecularhydrogeninstitute.com
and look at some of the many, many peer-reviewed studies. A lot of work has been done with
hydrogen breathing this. And just the hydrogen. Our machine does Brown's gas hydrogen, which
is a level up where it's working with the water structure like Gerald Pollack talks
about to make more of these little good guys in your body. So it's actually better than
molecular hydrogen, Brown's gas. But you can go on molecularhydrogeninstitute.com,
look at the studies. They've been doing a lot of work with people that have had strokes
to help them heal. Just breathing the molecular hydrogen. Again, not to get too redundant,
but our machine, AquaCure, does Brown's gas, which is a higher level with the water.
There's a fancy name for it, but it doesn't matter. The Gerald Pollack work with the fourth
level water. So it's cool. Check it out. Use promo code OneRadio, 10% discount, a lifetime
warranty, and a one-year no-questions-asked money-back warranty. When's the last time
you heard of somebody having a machine that does that? I mean, you could have this thing
for 10 months and say, "George, I don't want it. Give me my money back." You're not going
to do it because you'll like it. That's my opinion, but you have that option on
OneRadioNetwork.com.
I spend a lot of time in the outdoors, but I do live in the temperate zone. Wintertime
means that we're just not getting adequate sunlight to produce enough vitamin D. Even
if we went outside and exposed ourselves to the sun, there's just not enough UV because
of the angle the sun is at. A lot of people live in urban environments where buildings
effectively act like canyons, blocking sunlight. We wear a lot more clothing than ever before.
And now with things like lockdowns, people are simply not spending as much time outside
getting exposure to sun. So if you're not getting adequate vitamin D, you can end up
with chronically low levels, just like almost half of the American population. And that's
pretty scary because vitamin D3 deficiency has been implicated in many forms of cancer
and negative outcomes from things like flu and COVID. So it's really crucial that we
keep our dietary vitamin D3 up. And because a lot of the traditional foods like liver
and other organ meats that we used to eat that were rich in vitamin D3 are no longer
really represented in our diet, we need some kind of high quality vitamin D3 supplement.
That's why I love D3K2, Sir Thrival's Daylight Concentrate. It's naturally sourced vitamin
D3 from sheep's lanolin and K2 from Japanese natto. That's the most natural supplement
you're going to find anywhere. And at 270 doses per bottle, this is an incredibly good
value. Easy to take, just two drops a day. Get one for you, get one for your family members.
This is on any Sir Thrival link and you'll find the colostrum there, the elk velvet antler,
pine pollen, the digestive bitters, also the shaga and the reishi, everything in myron
glass, very high quality. We think you'll enjoy your experience with any Sir Thrival
product on OneRadioNetwork.com. One of my good friends is Brandon Amelani, used to work
with Daniel. Brandon has a company called Shen Blossom and he has very high quality,
all kind of tied in with Chinese medicine, some very ancient formulas. He has a 50 year
old ginseng, also he does shaga, reishi, some digestive bitters as well and also some digestive
powders that you can use. I like his detox formulas. Wonderful, wonderful products. Again,
everything in myron glass is like Daniel does. Check it out. We think you'll enjoy getting
something for over the holidays. Just all kinds of things. Very high quality on OneRadioNetwork.com.
Shen Blossom. And before we go back to Dr. Peat, remember we have what we think is one
of the best saunas ever. It's a portable sauna, $1,295, far infrared sauna, incredibly
low EMFs, there's no radio frequencies, little bit of magnetic energy from the floor
to the bottom of the chair and your head is sticking out as you can see if you see the
video. And you can sweat as long as you're getting your water and your little aminos,
you'll be fine. And I do it every day of my life, not that what I do matters, but we
think you'll enjoy this puppy. It's right on the front page of OneRadioNetwork.com.
Well, just click, I'm sorry, the only way you get this baby is to email me, Patrick
at OneRadioNetwork.com for a price that we're not allowed to kind of put in print, but just
to email me, Patrick@OneRadioNetwork.com and we'll give you the good price.
Broadcasting from the beautiful Hill Country in Texas, this is OneRadioNetwork.com.
We're with PhD Dr. Ray Peat. His website is RayPeat.com. I think it's Ray Peat, right?
Yeah, RayPeat.com. And also you can get his newsletter by emailing RayPeatsNewsletter,
plural, at gmail.com and it's very affordable. And Doc, when that comes out, what, every
few months, couple months? Yeah, I'm going to go from every other month
to quarterly this coming year. Oh, good for you. Yeah, good for you. I think
that's the right thing to do. So the next one will come out?
Every three months. Uh-huh. So it'll be April or March, something
like that? I'm not sure what the first one will be.
Yeah, this is a good question to start with and we get this a lot. What does Dr. Peat
think the reason why people feel better when they take ivermectin? I mean, because I don't
even know if there is a virus and, well, that's what they're saying. It's a long email, but
it is a good question. Why would people feel better taking ivermectin?
They believe they have this COVID virus, so they take ivermectin and they feel better.
I've heard that it does at least 20 different chemical effects in the body, but the essential
thing, I think, for feeling better as well as recovering more quickly is its anti-inflammatory
action. Just about any substance or process that is anti-inflammatory is also going to
be anti-coagulant to some extent and protect you against the clotting and bleeding syndromes
that are associated with COVID. I see. Isn't that interesting? I mean, essentially
it's ivermectin. Isn't it a kind of a parasite for horses kind of thing?
Yeah, it's a bacterial antibiotic substance, a very complex, fairly big molecule. It's
been used around the world for parasite treatment, billions of doses given to humans to cure
intestinal parasites. I guess it could be argued that many people
do have parasites, so they feel better if they go?
No, no. I think the reason they feel better is it has so many good effects related to
reducing inflammation. I see. How relevant is it for people when they
take something like ivermectin or hydroxychloroquine or something in their belief, the placebo,
that they are going to feel better? How do you feel about that?
Oh, the placebo effect is extremely powerful. The quinine derivatives, there are two synthetic
quinine-like drugs that are, for some reason, prescribed, I guess, cheapness or profitability.
Quinine is the basic thing that has a very broad spectrum of therapeutic value, but just
taking a bitter potion is going to have a fairly powerful placebo effect just because
you know it has potency if it tastes so bad and bitter.
Interesting. If it tastes yucky, right, it's got to be good for it.
Yeah, like we found a pill which is bright red is a more effective placebo than some
neutral colored pill. Isn't it interesting? Wow.
Would you please ask Dr. Peat, we'll get in the emails here, another one, about the
safety of consuming animal brain to raise cholesterol? Eating eggs and very high sugar
diet hasn't moved mine. Perhaps there is another alternative. Karen wants to get her
cholesterol number up.
In a medical school about 50 years ago, someone wondered how effective dietary cholesterol
really is at raising the blood level of cholesterol because of all of the fear of eating high
cholesterol food. So they had medical students eat every day a different quantity of eggs
and up to about 20 eggs per day, they didn't get a cholesterol increase in the blood.
Is that right?
In healthy people, but if they were very sick, they could get a cholesterol rise in the blood
from a smaller amount. But on average, I think it took the healthy medical students about
22 eggs per day to get a rise in their circulating cholesterol.
Well, what does that tell us about the healthy and the...
We powerfully regulate the amount of circulating cholesterol because it's an essential factor
in our health. And the reason cholesterol rises is that it's a defensive substance.
If you increase the amount of blood and just look at the ovaries' production of progesterone,
the amount of cholesterol in the blood going into the ovary exactly corresponds to the
amount of progesterone coming out of the ovary on the other side.
Oh.
And that means that when the blood level of cholesterol rises, your body is increasing
it so that the defensive protective hormones, including DHEA, progesterone, and pregnenolone
that these will be increased protectively.
So that's one of the arguments why folks try to get that cholesterol number up?
Yeah. And usually the most common reason for low cholesterol down around 140 milligrams
per cent, or it should be around 200, 160 to 220 or so. The thyroid level is what's
responsible for converting the cholesterol into the defensive substances. But if your
liver and intestine are very seriously damaged by poisons coming out of your intestine, then
you can't make enough cholesterol to circulate and turn into the protective steroids.
So the first thing to make sure your liver is able to produce the cholesterol you need
for the glands and brain and other tissues to produce the defensive progesterone, the
first thing you have to do is stop poisoning your liver by improving your digestion. The
thyroid and the protective hormones do protect your liver and intestine, but they can't
do the job alone if you're eating stuff that's very hard to digest and full of toxins.
For example, just eating a very big green salad every day. If a person is in perfect
health, it'll go right through them quickly, acting as a fiber. But if they're already
having sluggish digestion, that raw lettuce or spinach or whatever the leaves are will
sit in place being warm and exposed to bacteria so that it rots horribly before it gets out
of your system. And the toxins produced from something seemingly as innocuous as a green
salad can very powerfully limit your ability, your intestines and liver's ability to keep
up your cholesterol production.
Wow. So there's times depending on when salads are not the best choice, you'd be better to
cook the greens.
Yeah. That allows your actual digestive enzymes to extract something by breaking down the
cellulose that leaves only the bacteria to act on the raw leaves.
So what's going on in the digestion that is not allowing the raw salad to be a good thing?
What's happening? What are we lacking there?
Quick peristalsis.
Quick peristalsis. Yeah. So that's the colon making it, doing its thing to move things
through.
Yeah. Starting at your stomach, your stomach has to produce the digestive enzymes quickly,
move it on quickly, get your pancreas to excrete more of the digestive enzymes, get it to move
on as soon as the body has extracted what it can, then move the residue on quickly and
eliminate it. And the quicker it goes through, the cleaner your intestine is producing the
less lower amount of toxins.
And how do we ensure that we have these digestive enzymes? I've heard that if you take digestive
enzymes, it actually can teach your body not to make them.
No, I don't think that teaches, but you have to remember that the enzymes can't be cooked
to sterilize them. And so when you're eating a so-called enzyme, you're eating a raw animal
organ.
Not good.
And so you have to be ultra careful that they don't contain bacteria or other infective
material.
Wow. Have you ever found any that are okay to do digestive enzymes?
I think it's a matter of trial and error.
See what works.
But if you have a good thyroid function, as well as all of the essential nutrients, that's
the main thing for quick stomach emptying, quick pancreatic secretions, quick peristalsis
and quick elimination.
So that's why over the years you've focused so much on the thyroid and become really good
at understanding it, because if you get this little guy working, then everybody can play
along nicely.
Yeah, and there are some foods that can be therapeutic while waiting for your thyroid
health to be normalized.
And what are those?
My first experience was with a raw carrot every day.
Oh, that's right. Yeah, raw carrot.
I stopped having migraines as long as I ate a raw carrot every day.
But then I found that taking thyroid, I was no longer so absolutely dependent on the daily
carrot.
And there are several other fibers that are just about as safe as carrot.
The carrot contains some toxins, but plant materials in general do.
The high fiber content of the raw carrot prevents almost all of the toxins from being absorbed.
You don't even get much carotene.
For example, if you just chew your carrot or if you shred it lengthwise so it doesn't
produce a lot of juice, you don't want to put a carrot through a blender because that
releases most of the carotene to be absorbed.
So you like to shred it like you do it on a cheese shredder kind of thing?
Yeah, there are food processors that will make a nice, fine shreddy.
And don't you put something on it too, if I recall?
Olive oil tastes really good, salt and vinegar.
And it happens that both the oil, olive oil and vinegar, which is a saturated fatty acid,
that these are antiseptics.
And the fiber of the carrot distributes the vinegar and oil all along your intestine.
If you just drank the oil and vinegar, it would be gone.
That's great.
And what are some of these other than carrots that do similar things with the high fiber?
Very well cooked mushrooms are pretty effective.
Very well cooked bamboo shoots and the traditional oat bran.
Oat bran.
Yeah, the bran has some of the same effects.
It has a very low calorie content.
It makes a very pleasant breakfast cereal to make a porridge out of the oat bran.
Just oat bran.
What about steel cut oats?
Are they good?
Do they work?
The what?
Steel cut oats.
Oh, yeah, I think any oatmeal is--
Got some good stuff.
Yeah.
It could be rolled oats or just the grain is fibrous enough that it has a good effect.
I think the drawback that scares some people away from it is that experiments have found
that the oatmeal as usually consumed contains, I think it's phytic acid that binds the minerals.
I'm not sure it's phytic acid, but anyway, something that binds the magnesium and calcium
so that according to those experiments, the more oatmeal you eat, the less calcium and
magnesium your body can absorb.
If you're going to eat oatmeal, you have to make sure to get extra milk.
Milk, yeah, good old milk.
Here's an email for Dr. Ray Peat, Patrick Timpone.
Dr. Peat is here on the third Monday.
We're going to stay around after we let Dr. Peat go and hang out and talk a little bit
before we take a couple weeks off for vacation.
My wife has been diagnosed, writes an email, or with my-- you know what I'm saying, myasthenia
gravis.
How do you say that first word, doc?
Myasthenia.
Myasthenia gravis.
Does Dr. Peat have any suggestions that what could be the cause and the help with this
condition?
I've seen improvement just by correcting the thyroid function.
Really?
Wow.
Just the thyroid function.
And again, you kind of focus in, if I understand, on the TSH, right?
And you want this guy down there to, what'd you say, .2?
Yeah, below 0.4.
I'm sorry, 0.4.
It's fairly safe, but it's fine to be even lower than that.
Wow.
And the body temperature is the other thing.
The combination of a low TSH with a good warm body temperature that stays around 98.6 for
the bulk of the daytime.
And in the morning, at least 98 or so to when you wake up?
Yeah, 97.8 is okay if you warm up after breakfast.
So, say if you had your thyroid kind of low under 1 and your temperature is still colder,
you'd want to increase the thyroid stuff, the PIG.
Yeah, generally it could be other hormones lacking.
So, you want to make sure your whole nutritional intake has all of the essential minerals and
vitamins and quantity of protein and carbohydrate.
All the good stuff.
Could you please ask Dr. Peat another email?
Excuse me.
What he thinks of astaxanthin.
It's touted to me in many benefits.
Thanks for having on the show every week.
Do you know that one, astaxanthin?
Oh, yeah.
It's in the same family as keratin.
It's an antioxidant, but I'm not too enthusiastic about that general family.
Too much of it can interfere with your thyroid function.
In that family, what family is that?
The keratin family.
I think that's where this...
Astaxanthin, isn't it in the family of like greens or like coloella, spirulina?
Maybe not.
Yeah.
My impression is that it's related to the keratin.
Keratin.
What family is that?
What are some other keratin family things?
They are precursors or related to vitamin A.
Ah, vitamin A.
The other mostly yellow and orange pigments are the flavonoids.
The bulk of them, there are thousands of different flavonoids, but the largest number of them
are very protective anti-inflammatory things where the carotenoids can even associate with
increased cancer, increased damage to the skin from sunburn and so on.
Does Dr. Ray Peat think it's a good idea to take supplemental iodine for thyroid function?
No, almost never.
There are several dozen studies of the iodine intake around the world that increased when
they started iodizing salt and found that even I think it's somewhere around, well,
half a milligram a day associates strongly with damage to the thyroid gland and eventually
loss of thyroid function.
Do you think this could be the reason when they started doing the iodized salt thing?
Could this have been a reason why people have thyroid issues?
I think that's part of it.
Wow, fascinating.
When did the iodized salt thing happen?
It did cure a lot of the goiters and hypothyroid, some regions.
I think parts of China and South America are still very iodine deficient, but outside of
those areas, the supplemental iodine is more likely to cause damage over the years.
That's why we're kind of fans of, say, like the pickling and canning, just pure salt.
Then that's one of the reasons why you're not a big proponent of these expensive sea
salts because they got a lot of other stuff in there?
Yeah, if they aren't purified, that means that at best it will be some of the clay and
mud from the beach where it's collected.
Probably don't need that, right?
It's hard to predict what kind of harmful minerals might be in that clay.
The pink salt is very high in iron, so I don't think it's good to use regularly.
They charge you extra for the pink salt, Doc.
You know that.
That's right.
Here's a question for Dr. Peat from Mike.
If Dr. Peat was elected to replace Dr. Fauci as the chief medical advisor, what recommendations
would he make to the American people with regard to the COVID pandemic?
Interesting question.
First, I would look at all of the data, any data that had ever been claimed to be a basis
for saying that there is a pandemic.
Make that public.
Instead of stonewalling when someone sues the government public health agency, instead
of keeping the basis for the pandemic existing, instead of keeping it secret, the first thing
would be to look at the data that they claimed was confirming the existence of such a thing
as a pandemic.
So far, no such evidence has been found.
What they did was subsidize people to make up horrible possibilities, imaginary scenarios
of what might happen, and then that was presented as the science rather than a government-supported
hypothesis about the horrible possibilities.
Yeah, yeah, Stefan Leinke and these other folks, as you know, they claim that there
was the original thing was some kind of snot from somebody and the whole thing was a computer-generated
model.
Yeah, and one of the most under-discussed facts that is right open to everyone is that
right after the pandemic was declared, up to that point through history, there had been
thousands of people dying seasonally from influenza, ordinary flu, and varieties of
pneumonia.
But the week, the second week of April 2020, when there was this horrible spike in deaths
so-called from COVID, that week flu went out of existence around the world.
You don't have influenza committing suicide just so that the same amount of deaths could
be blamed on COVID.
It was simply a renaming of deaths that were happening anyway.
Yes, sir.
Well, let me just do this email from George.
"What does Dr. Peat make of the videos that I've seen of these football players?"
It's called soccer over there.
"Up to 100 have already had myocardial infarctions, heart attacks."
Was that following a vaccine?
Yes.
Yeah, the figures are clear that the vaccine is pro-inflammatory, pro-coagulation, and
with excess coagulation, the risk of bleeding, internal bleeding.
So it's a series of very closely related things.
Inflammation causes coagulation, coagulation depletes the defense, and you can end up with
a bleeding stroke.
Go ahead.
I'm sorry.
The number of heart attacks is very, very clearly connected to the vaccination.
And do we know what the result of any of these extra boosters is?
You know, Mr. Fauci, now they're talking about there's going to be two or three or maybe
once a year.
Is there any idea, or is this so new that we have no idea what these boosters could
do to people?
I think so far they've just been the same thing over and over.
Is it just the same thing?
More of the same.
You can't, even with the phony so-called vaccine principle of the RNA, you can't keep up with
the changes in the virus.
You can't fight an epidemic in process with vaccines.
It's never been rational.
It's simply a fraudulent scheme to keep people under control.
Do you think the truth of this, Dr. Ray Peat, on this December 20 day will ever come out?
What's your theory?
Do you think it will ever come out?
It's out.
Of course, it's out.
It's a matter of whether you want to look at it.
The people who are convinced that it's a crime not to be vaccinated are never going to look
at the evidence.
You don't think they will?
No.
They're actually locking people down in Sweden and other places like that who haven't been
vaccinated.
Locking them down.
Putting them in prison camps.
Yes, sir.
Here's an email from a lady, the fellow that I live with, who I love, is being forced,
well, he doesn't have to, but he thinks he's being forced to get a booster shot.
I'm wondering if I need to refrain from kissing and sex for some time after he gets it.
Yeah, the shedding, the phenomenon of shedding was known long before the vaccine.
People are always putting out in their sweat, urine, body fluids, and even breath, the proteins
and pieces of DNA and RNA that are circulating in their blood.
They come right out of the person into the air and surroundings.
That's established.
If you have a new circulating material in the body, the vaccine, they simply asserted
that it wouldn't get away from your arm lymph nodes, that it wouldn't get into your general
circulation.
It was shown to circulate in the bloodstream, concentrated in the gonads and the spleen
and other tissues.
They're still saying, even though now it's acknowledged to circulate to all of the organs
to some extent, they're saying it can't get into the breastfeeding woman's milk for the
same reason that it couldn't get into the bloodstream.
So if it can't get into the milk, naturally the vaccine can't make the baby sick, except
there's no fact to support their claims.
We had a virologist on, Dr. Janci Lindsay, a very well-respected lady who's testified
in court cases and all this.
She laid out a pretty eloquent argument with science and peer reviews and from people all
over the world that these things are going all over the body, just as you just said.
Everywhere.
All the organs.
Since the vaccine has its course from the arm through your bloodstream to the various
organs, it settles out into those organs and gradually disappears from the bloodstream.
So it's thought that the maximum shedding is going to be while it's circulating through
your bloodstream, getting into your breath and sweat and so on.
Naturally, if it gets into your sweat, it's able to get into the breast milk.
So is that an argument that for this emailer to after some time, she wouldn't have to
be concerned with her significant other?
Yeah, possibly up to a month, but usually the first two weeks after vaccination is when
you're most likely to be shedding.
So if I understand though, what I heard you say, correct me if I'm wrong, that we are
always shedding or sharing whatever you want to call them, exosomes or virus, with everybody,
aren't we?
All the time?
Yeah, everything that circulates in the blood, surprisingly, even long strips of bare nucleic
acids, it doesn't have to be encapsulated in the lipid to go through blood vessels and
so on.
As controls, they've injected bare DNA and found that it went right through so-called
cell membranes, got inside cells.
And so that stuff circulating in the blood is always, some of it blows out through your
lungs.
So if you put a cold object under your nose that allows condensation on the cold and then
analyze that, you'll find proteins, fats, RNA, DNA, bits of everything.
It's just the way it works.
What's your theory of why it's been set up like this from God or whichever belief system
one has?
Why would it be like this?
The exosomes actually come out in your breath and body fluids.
And so spreading through the urine, the sweat, and the breath, these are sharing our genetic
discoveries with all of our colleagues.
Everyone is sharing the patterns that are a part of their life.
And it turns out that like bacteria share the particles that make them immune to antibiotics.
They'll pass them on not only to related bacteria but even to stranger bacteria across
species or types of bacteria.
So as a species, we're essentially trying to help one another get healthier in a way,
right?
Yeah.
In the case of bacteria, it's very clear.
The same process happens among plants and animals of all sorts.
But we think in terms almost which may be incorrect as bacteria being bad that we don't
want any.
Yeah.
Sometimes the bacteria will shed things that we don't want that are poisonous to us.
But also the bacteria has been said to be a healing process too.
Yeah, on balance, we've done pretty well with the bacteria environment.
The bulk effect has been good.
So if Dr. Peat or Patrick or our listeners allow a, say maybe a strep throat to happen,
let the bacteria heal the tissues as many argue rather than get an antibiotic, that
bacteria then can be shared with others so they can do the same thing?
No, your throat shouldn't let the bacteria reach that point.
Oh.
A healthy person can have the same germs present but they aren't hurting anything.
So there's a failure in the ground substance that you can't blame entirely on the bacteria.
But so, are you advocating then if somebody has strep throat to get an antibiotic?
Yeah, once it has reached the point of pain, getting rid of it is quick and then figuring
out why you've allowed that bacteria to go crazy.
But doesn't when we take an antibiotic, Dr. Peat, kind of mess a lot of things up?
Yeah, but you only should take it to get rid of the problem, not try to kill everything.
Right.
Lots of people get carried away and kill off all of the bacteria in their intestine and
then that lets, since the antibiotic is harming your own host cells, it's weakening your mitocytes.
It's weakening your mitochondria.
You only want to take the minimum that will shift the balance in your favor.
So if they give you 20 and the pain goes away in two days, you can stop there?
Yeah, give it maybe half a day of tapering off just to make sure it's gone.
Wow.
But don't do the whole two things.
They always tell you to do the whole thing though, don't they?
Yeah, they don't want to have to pay attention or think about it.
Okay, I love them.
Rachel writes in, "Could you please ask Dr. Peat to what causes the body to attack
itself as in an autoimmune disease?
I have an autoimmune disease in which my body is supposedly attacking my muscles and causing
muscle weakness.
What would be the best diet and supplement for something like this?"
My current newsletter has a little bit about that.
The histamine, for example, activated by estrogen and many other things, but histamine and estrogen
and endotoxin, each of those tends to make your tissues take up water, get inflamed,
start producing more histamine or analogous things, release endotoxin from your intestine
to circulate through your bloodstream.
The histamine effect in cells is causing a local uptake of water, a change of the protein
relation to the surrounding water and activation of the cell excitation shift to inefficient
metabolism towards lactic acid production, for example.
These transmitters that change the metabolism are changing the antigenic properties of the
cell.
It doesn't take a powerful chemical reaction.
Just a stretching or excess bending or swelling of a tissue can change the protein confirmation
enough that it becomes antigenic.
Your immune system sees what looks like a foreign antigen because of these intrinsic
pro-inflammatory signals.
The cell is swelling up and getting deranged.
To the immune system, at an extreme, that looks like a foreign material.
The immune system comes in and tries to clean up the damage the way it would with a bacteria
or fungal infection.
It kills the cells and carries away the debris as far as possible.
Although these same components, histamine and estrogen, for example, will shift your
immune system, knocking out the brain of your immune system, the thymus cells, suppressing
them and releasing the antibody-forming B cells.
At the same time, activating an enzyme that creates actual genetic change, a genomic destabilization
enzyme, they call it AID, that produces novel antibodies.
We're generating more and more antibodies under the influence of estrogen and histamine.
The immune system seems to be going a little crazy, but what it's doing is revving up and
trying to clear away the tissue damage, which is the basic problem.
I think of it as the tissue damage as being primary.
If you stop the inflammation, restore oxidative metabolism and energy production, you restore
a lot of those proteins to their natural conformation so they are no longer anagenic, then your
immune system will be able to quiet down and stop attacking.
So the autoimmune model that we've heard about, it literally does attack tissues that it shouldn't
be because it's confused?
Yeah.
Once you've activated the B cells to produce more and more antibodies, they're less discriminant
and so they'll start trying to remove too many cells and make the inflammation worse.
But you've got to turn off the inflammation first and then worry about getting rid of
the antibodies.
When you're hypothyroid, your thyroid tissue is under stress and you'll form antibodies
to those stressed thyroid cells, but all you have to do is supplement the needed amount
of thyroid hormone and nutrients and allow the TSH to stop overdriving and stressing
your thyroid gland.
Gradually over a period of six months to a year, those antithyroid antibodies will fade
away.
Fascinating.
We came across a website that might be of interest, if they're accurate.
It seems that they would be.
They're very professional, the whole thing.
It's called Let's Get Checked.
For a very small amount, you can get a test kit and do a blood thing and you can test
your TSH just at home.
Oh, that would be convenient.
Yeah.
I did mine and that's how I found out mine was where it was.
I suspect it's accurate.
You'd have no way of knowing, but it seems like they know what they're doing.
It's called Let's Get Checked.
It might be interesting for people.
You could just do your TSH.
I think it was like $75 or something.
Having a lot of friends writes an email asking how to detox from the vaccine.
Can Dr. Peat, does he have some ideas about this?
Yeah, I think treating it exactly the way you would treat the COVID infection because
the spike protein is what causes the inflammatory coagulation damage and the spike protein occurs
from the vaccine just as much as from the virus itself.
Doing the same anti-inflammatory things.
That would be aspirin, antihistamines, even glucocorticoids or progesterone will help
to reduce the inflammation.
Having enough carbohydrate in your diet to restrain histamine production as part of it.
Don't fast or eat a pure protein diet.
That would tend to increase the inflammation and coagulation.
On the histamine thing, you want to get adequate carbohydrates for that not to get up, right?
Can you ask Dr. Peat about ways of protecting yourself from vaccine shedding?
Maybe the same kind of answer?
Not being around crowds that are likely to be shedding.
I think things like a sudden burst of nosebleeds or untimely menstruation and so on.
I think those are likely effects of crowd-induced shedding poisoning.
It's December 20, 2021.
Patrick Timpone, we're going to stick around after we let Dr. Peat go and spend some time
with you before we take a couple weeks off.
Aaron writes in, "I have a toothache and the gum around the tooth is inflamed.
Does Dr. Peat have any suggestions what I can do?"
Very often that starts with something you ate.
I had that experience for many years.
An incipient tooth abscess or abscess below a tooth would flare up as soon as I ate potatoes
or tomatoes.
It was a way of training me to stop eating the foods that were affecting my mouth as
well as my intestine.
Fascinating.
Wow.
Here's an email.
"I want to take a liquid supplement orally that has DMSO as a solvent.
If I'm not allergic to DMSO, is 200 mg of DMSO orally a safe amount to take every day
in the long term?"
Using it as a solvent for what?
They're asking about a liquid supplement that has a little bit of DMSO in there.
I've never heard of that.
I think not a good thing to take every day.
Why would you take DMSO internally?
They have found that it has an anti-inflammatory effect.
It helps the same way progesterone and anti-inflammatory things do to let the cell give up some of
the water it shouldn't have.
But there are so many safer ways to reduce inflammation in cells.
You can't always count on the DMSO being as pure as it should be.
It can carry trace allergens into your tissues.
Here's an interesting question for you, "Doc, any ideas of why my long brown hair is thinning
so much it breaks off at the shaft right where the follicle enters the scalp comes out with
the slightest pull?"
That's most often an effect of low thyroid.
In animal studies, they find that, for example, a woman who was using estrogen cream found
that her fuzzy dogs were going bald just from being in contact with her skin.
The estrogen tends to end the cycle of the fascia right here.
Low thyroid slows the growth and thins the shaft diameter.
It gets weaker and weaker as your thyroid is lower and the estrogen higher.
Boy, that's just an incredible thing when you think about it.
The TSH, you're talking about 0.4 for thyroid function.
That's so much lower than what is generally believed to be the right TSH level.
Oh yeah.
Just lately, I've heard from several people with a 4.something TSH and they're obviously
sick and their symptoms are all traceable to an excess of TSH.
TSH itself is pro-inflammatory and just lowering it is going to improve your symptoms, but
increasing the metabolic rate by supplementing thyroid with the anti-inflammatory effect
of getting rid of excess TSH.
If you're experimenting with your thyroid, whether it be PIGGY or whatever it is, Doc,
how long would you want to be on it before you could reliably say, "Well, I'm going
to do another quick TSH maybe with this company to see where it is."
How long would you want to be on it before it would be relevant?
Since it's very hard to predict what dose you need, it's important to monitor your daily
reaction by checking your pulse rate and temperature at waking and middle of the day and to gradually
increase the dose until you're at an optimal body temperature and pulse rate.
Only at that point should you bother to check the TSH again because the temperature and
pulse rate are going to be changing as you're adapting to the dose.
How do we know what would be just the right pulse rate for us, for you and I and our listeners?
Whatever works for you to some extent, but when you look at both healthy populations
versus sick populations or if you look at people in a given state of health who happen
to have a heart pacemaker, for example, they've given mental acuity tests to people with a
different heart rate or with a pacemaker installed.
If they run the heart at 70 beats and have a certain quality of memory and reasonability,
then they turn it up to 80 beats per minute and give them the test again.
All of their mental faculties have improved just by increasing the heart rate a little
above 70.
Same with very healthy, very alert people.
They tend to have faster heart rates.
Females too have faster heart rates in general, don't they?
Yeah.
Women have smaller hearts than men and like kids have much faster pulse rates because
their heart is smaller and their metabolic rate is higher.
Women generally have a slower metabolic rate than men, but with a smaller heart, you have
to consider their body temperature and body size and so on to judge what each one means.
But again, then in the afternoon, say one or two o'clock, if you're just hanging around
the house, you want to really try to be at 98.6 and that's a good indication of what
your TSH is doing?
Very close in the long run.
Wow, fascinating.
An emailer says, "Doesn't orange juice spike your insulin?
I try to keep my carbs under 50 grams per day."
Oh, why do you want to keep it there?
I don't know.
That's what she said.
How would you make up the calorie difference with too much protein can be pro-inflammatory
and anti-metabolic, slowing your thyroid function and lowering your temperature.
Carbohydrates are really the most adjustable because sugar tends to increase your heat
production and metabolic rate.
Calcium and vitamin D are other things that increase your ability to oxidize calories.
I think anything up to over 200 grams a day is fine as long as your calorie intake is
in balance and your heat production is good.
Is there any way to protect oneself from airplane radiation while traveling?
The cosmic radiation, the scare about high altitude radiation was invented by the nuclear
industry.
People at high altitudes have much lower incidence of cancer despite the higher cosmic ray intensity.
The cosmic rays per unit of radiation are less harmful than the lower energy.
It's a matter of what they call linear energy transfer.
It means that low energy x-ray is more toxic than high energy x-ray.
Gamma rays are higher energy than x-rays and they're less toxic because they transfer less
energy to the tissues.
Particle radiation is ordinarily far more toxic than the electromagnetic x-rays, ultraviolet
or gamma rays because the particle slows down and gives up all of its energy to the tissue.
But in the case of cosmic rays, they are so extremely fast moving that they give up a
much smaller amount of energy to harm the tissue.
This is anecdotal, but I have a good friend of mine who is over 80.
He's one of the healthiest guys I know and he was a pilot his whole life.
If that whole pilot thing or flying, he wouldn't even be around.
It was so dangerous.
Yeah, insurance companies have known for more than 100 years that living at very high altitudes,
you have less cancer and heart disease mortality.
Now his hair is totally white and he said it's been white most of his life.
That's interesting.
I don't know how that happened.
Here's Lydia.
A couple more then we'll let you go, Doc.
Your salt has not been iodized for so long now.
Most people are deficient.
See Dr. Brownstein's work on this especially with regard to bromine-iodine relationship.
Yeah, Brownstein was a follower of Guy Abraham.
I think there's a lot of assertion, almost no science behind those claims.
It's only these two or three people descended mentally from Abraham, the pro-iodine.
He sold an iodine product.
Now you're not talking about like Abraham, biblical Abraham, somebody else?
No, no.
Dr. Abraham.
I mean a fellow that sold an iodine product and that's where this all came from?
Yeah, his website.
Although he worked in the same lab before I did doing hamster aging research.
After that, I think his whole thing was to sell his products.
His website had totally insane stuff about radiation and iodine.
After I ridiculed it, the worst of it disappeared.
Didn't Edgar Cayce, wasn't he claimed that he helped the body cure from some, what was
it with iodine?
Was it some kind of plague thing or do you know what I mean?
Yeah, it was used to, scrofula was the original thing, but it was a traditional anti-inflammatory
antiseptic drug.
And generally, Edgar Cayce said was pretty well founded, but I think you have to interpret
the iodine stuff very carefully.
Oh, so I didn't quite get that.
So he was on to something with the iodine?
What disease was I'm thinking of that he used it for?
It was somebody in India.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
It has been successfully used for a lot of things.
Heart disease, hardening of the arteries, breast tumors even.
But we don't need it now, you argue.
No, we've been oversupplied with dietary iodine now.
For example, bread and baked goods, for a long time were using an iodine dough conditioner
to make the dough produce lighter bread, just using for a physical effect an iodine compound.
That alone was giving the American population for decades a toxic overdose of iodine.
Do we get iodine when we eat fresh fish as well?
Yeah, having a serving of fish from the ocean once a week will pretty much guarantee our
adequate iodine.
And any seaweed kind of stuff too would give us plenty of iodine, right?
Yeah, but you can overdose.
A lot of people overdose by using iodine-rich seaweed.
And what would the symptoms be of an overdose?
I think it contributes to the high incidence of nearsightedness in the Japanese.
And antithyroid effect can show up as nearsightedness.
Wow, interesting.
Final one, this is a good question.
Somebody just wrote in here, our friend Adam Bergstrom, Dr. Peat, he said Guy E. Abraham.
I'm not sure how you pronounce his first name, but French would be Guy.
Guy E. Abraham, that's who you're talking about in this iodine thing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Final one, so Dr. Peat just said that the thyroid has to do a lot with hair follicles
and calling it a low thyroid TSH reading.
Would increasing my dosage help with the hair falling out as I am on two-grain natural thyroid
and would it raise my heart rate if I increased it?
So she's right now on two grains, which is what, 120 milligrams?
Yeah, that was the average dose for decades, using farmer's thyroid.
And would that, do you think the average dose is higher now for any reason?
No, it's probably around 120.
And again, if somebody wasn't sure, they can either do the test or work with the body temperature
and the pulse.
Yeah, you definitely don't want to start right out with two grains.
Even if that's what you're going to end up with in six months as a starting dose, it
could easily cause heart pains or it will imbalance your nutrients to go at it too suddenly.
Oh, finally, do you think even the best of food grade or food source vitamins are reasonable
to take?
What was the last trait?
Food source, like all from food and organic foods, some kind of vitamin supplement, they
have good liquid ones that appear to be good.
Do you think it's reasonable to play with those?
No.
If they're supposed to be extracted from foods, they're going to be far more expensive than
the food would be.
Right, yes.
, and in the process of extracting them, very often extraneous materials get in and
you lose some of the active ingredients.
Yeah, well, Dr. Peat, such an honor to have you on and thanks so much for coming on here
once a month.
We really, really appreciate it.
God love you.
Okay, it's always fun.
Yeah, well, I'm glad you have a good time and glad you keep coming.
So we'll see you next year, huh?
Have fun.
Santa Claus coming around your house, do you think?
Probably.
Oh, well, good.
Well, that's great.
Sir, thank you.
I love you and you let us know if we can help and we'll see you third week in January.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Dr. Ray Peat, Patrick Timpone, OneRadioNetwork.com.
He's the bomb, huh?
Yep.
I tell you what, I like his stuff.
Well, you know what we're going to do here just because it's my kind of last day with
you before I go on a little vacay.
What do you say I just go to a little boys room?
That's probably more information than what you need.
And then we'll just come back in about five minutes and hang out for a little bit.
We'll go through some of the news.
If you want to call in, 888-663-6386.
And we'll just play around for a little bit before we kind of wrap up our 2021 year with
you as we're going to take some time off and come back on the third with Adam Bergstrom.
I think it's the third of January.
So stay right there.
Thank you.
Pass on these links to everyone that you care about.
If you'd like to look at our videos, they're on BitChute.
The link is right on the top front of OneRadioNetwork.com.
Sign up for Telegram.
We have quite a nice group we're developing there.
The Telegram link, it's a social media network platform that doesn't censor anybody.
And we're back on Facebook now after being in jail for 30 days, but I'm pretty feisty
so I don't know how long that's going to last.
But email me if I can help with anything.
Our website will be here all year round.
I mean all the rest of the last two weeks.
So if you need something, don't be shy about ordering up from all of our fine people you
see on the front page.
We've got some really, really nice products.
No matter what it is, Sulphur, Sana, we'll take care of it.
You'll get things shipped out before the end of the year.
I'll still be around the computer.
So whatever you want to order, if I can help you with anything, let me know.
Patrick at OneRadioNetwork.com.
I love you all very much.
We'll see you in about five minutes and we'll hang out for a little bit before we go.
From the hill country in Texas, this is OneRadioNetwork.com.